[Music]
the vampire and Lycan clans have been at
war for centuries turning our world into
a battlefield for me the fight is
personal everyone I've ever loved has
been hunted there now a new war is being
waged Selene the lichens are moving
again they have a new leader
Marius I'm finished with this war well
it's not finished with you he wants the
blood of you and your daughter even I
don't know where she is
I needed to deliver a message tell your
Marius I'm coming for him do you
understand your message
we need saline at the end the war
she is the purest aalverson she is the
key the futures of lichens and vampires
and when we have the flood of saline and
her daughter will be invincible
you must go north you will find answers
there if you want to win this war you
will need to go further than even a
warrior of your renown has ever ventured
before impossible
there's nothing stopping her now
there are too many of them do I look
worried
what I want is your blood
come & get it
you
everyone I've ever loved has been hunted
down now a new war is being waged this
day was